in a world where things are changing at
hyper speed how can businesses make the
right calls
they turn to business analysts from
business expansion to reinvestment
strategies
what if you could be the one giving
business leaders the real-time insights
they never had
to make high-impact business decisions
they could never make before
what if you had not just the tools but
also the job-ready understanding of how
to use them
in just six months without quitting your
job and at a fraction of an on-campus
program fee
welcome to our unique postgraduate
program in business analysis
in partnership with purdue university
and in collaboration with ibm
learn the in-demand ba skills and tools
from today's top practitioners
with an iiba aligned cutting-edge
curriculum covering everything from
requirement analysis
analytics and agile to tools such as
jira
excel tableau and python get the best
out of your learning with this six month
boot camp
designed to give you both the practical
understanding and the knowledge to crack
other top certification exams in the
field
learn by doing experience a high
engagement classroom environment with 8
times higher interaction
and 100 plus hours of live collaborative
sessions
perfect all the skills learned with over
eight real world industry projects
and the capstone in three domains
experiential learning via harvard
business case studies
ibm hackathons and master classes from
faculty at purdue university
immerse yourself in a world-class
industry-aligned curriculum
that not only covers the core business
analysis tools and skills but provides
360-degree learning with hand-picked
courses on data analysis
modeling reporting project management
and highly relevant complementary skills
including digital transformation and
change management
and at the end of six months you get to
march out to your new world
stronger confident and more prepared
than ever before
with a joint pgp purdue certificate in
hand
purdue alumni membership and a uniquely
competitive skill set that top hiring
companies are on the lookout for
so what's the weight for them fill out a
two minute application form
and your personal admissions consultant
will be in touch with the prerequisites
we hope to see you at our next cohort